-Jaden, thanks again
for being here.
Now, you are an extremely
creative person.
You're always finding new ways
to express yourself.
So I thought, it would be fun to
challenge you to a new game
called "Selfie expression."
Here we go.
-♪ Ah! ♪
-♪ Selfie expression ♪
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-Wow.
That's a theme right --
-That's awesome.
-That's a theme right there.
Oh, my God.
♪ Wha! ♪
Okay, here we go.
Earlier today we were given
a list of words,
and this really happened.
A list of words, feelings,
or emotions,
and for each one we
had to take a selfie,
interpreting that feeling or
emotion however we wanted.
So it is time now to
compare our photos.
Our first prompt was fear.
-So...
-Mm!
Here was the photo I took.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
That's the one!
-[ Laughs ]
-That's the one!
It's like something's --
-Oh, that's the one!
-Something's attacking me.
I don't know what it is.
It could be --
I think I went back to
like almost like
a Godzilla type
of movie or something,
where something from above
is attacking.
-It's like a -- yeah, it's like
a flying -- yeah.
That's amazing. I love that.
-Yes, it is a flying thing.
-I'm hoping mine doesn't
disappoint.
-Now here we go. Here's the
photo that you took.
Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm like --
I'm hiding behind my fingers,
like, watching a scary
movie or something.
-Oh, I see. All right, let's
look at these side by side.
-Yeah. We need to see them
side by side.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man.
-No, yours -- please.
This is --
-Yours.
-I don't know what I'm doing.
That's not --
Mine's not fear. Mine's --
-You won that one.
-Really?
You're going to give it to me?
-Yeah, I think --
-I felt like that's bizarre.
-I think I have to
give it to you.
-All right, I'm gonna take it.
I'll take it, I got fear.
Love it. All right.
Our next prompt was thirst.
That was a tough one for me.
-Yes, yes.
-Here's the photo I took.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know.
All right.
Could be thirst, could be dead.
I have no idea
what that photo is.
[ Laughter ]
Here's the photo you took.
-Yes!
-Similar! That's the one.
-That's the one.
Dude, that looks --
-Oh, that looks refreshing.
Let's put them
next to each other.
-You got --
-Yes!
-No, yeah, you got thirst.
-Yes.
-Mine was confusing,
what that -- please --
-That's the one.
-You got the one right there.
That is actually --
that's a great photo.
There we go. All right.
I like that one.
This next one --
-I worked hard on that one.
-Our next prompt was
anticipation.
Anticipation. Here we go.
-Anticipation.
-Here's the photo I took.
-Wow!
-No, I don't know.
That's ridiculous. That's --
-No, no, no.
You're -- you're like --
it looks like you're
anticipating, like,
a meteor falling down.
[ Laughter ]
-It could also be fear.
[ Laughs ]
All my pictures are fear.
All right, let me see
your anticipation.
-Oh, I don't --
-That's it.
No, that's it.
-That's it?
Ah! I was just like,
"What are you doing?"
It's like, I don't know
what I'm anticipating.
I'm like,
"Uh, what's over there?
What's happening?"
-Darn it.
-Something not right
is going on.
-Let's put side by side.
-Yeah.
No, I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm doing it bad.
-No, you got this one.
I think you got this one.
-I'm doing a bad
Jim Carrey impression.
I don't know what I'm doing.
-I'm do--
[ Laughter ]
I'm doing like, "Hey..."
I'm doing some awful --
that's not anticipating.
No one would ever do that.
They're --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Yours is going, "Wait,
what are you going to do?
What are about to do to me?"
That's a smarter take.
-What's going on?
Yes.
-Just creeping.
-That's a smarter take.
I'm going like, "Aah!
I can't believe --"
"'Mulan' is only 30 bucks!"
You know, stuff like that.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
Lastly our final prompt was,
hangry.
-Hangry.
-Here's the photo I took.
-Wow!
-Yeah. I went to --
I went to cannibalism.
-I'm nervous that you got me
on this one, because --
-I went straight to what would
I do if I was really hangry?
I would probably eat --
eat my own arm.
-Totally.
Totally.
-All right, here's the photo
you took.
Wait, what?
[ Laughter ]
Shut -- That's -- No!
That's the other photo.
Come on!
[ Laughs ]
That is anticipation.
That's anticipation.
-Yeah. That's anticipation.
That's not hangry.
-You got it.
-Oh, my gosh.
Buddy, you are the best.
Thank you for playing with me.
Thanks for hanging out.
Jaden Smith, everybody.